bonsoir à toutes et tous
je vais
parler ce soir d'une forme par
kühl hier de 10
si mais aussi d'inhumanité et peut-être
plus encore de l'ambition d'humanité
qu'est ce que la nouvelle diplomatie en
fait c'est une démonstration de la
pertinence de savoir s'affranchir du
politiquement correct et j'espère à
travers quelques exemples de success
story vous en convaincre et vous inviter
à en partager les raisons d'y croire
le premier exemple de transgression ou
d'insoumission a été la création même de
l' ong handicap international
il y à quelques 35 ans finalement notre
notre seul mérite a été dosé donné
raison à celles et ceux qui avaient
trouvé une solution pour elles mêmes ou
pour leurs proches
en fabriquant des appareillages de
fortune avec du bois avec des pneus usés
avec du bambou ou bien même avec des
emballages d'obus récupérés sur les
champs de bataille des au but sens 5 ou
de 120 selon la taille de leurs moignon
alors il faut il faut se souvenir que
cette période dans les années 70 80 les
mines antipersonnel avait été utilisée
massivement quelques temps plus tard
quand nous irons au cambodge en janvier
80 quand l'accès au cambodge sera devenu
possible
nous découvrons que ce petit pays à
l'économie ravagée devait faire face à
une population de 27 mille amputé plus
tard nous découvrirons que l'afghanistan
en comptait quelque 70000 par la suite
au mozambique en angola nous sommes
qu'ils se comptaient par dizaines de
milliers on était là très très loin des
prétentions des militaires qui parle de
dommages collatéraux
la crise des mines antipersonnel était
véritablement un fléau planer planétaire
au bout d'un certain nombre d'années
handicapés nationale a pris conscience
d'une obligation nouvelle celle de
tenter d'enrayer la prolifération
insensé de cette arme
c'est légalement d'enrayer les
mutilations programmée de dizaines de
milliers de nouvelles victimes civiles
chaque année et pour cela au fond c'est
une fois encore une forme d' à
soumission qui nous a invités à entrer
en politique
pour cela nous avons scellé une alliance
avec un certain nombre de d'organisation
humanitaire human rights watch
c'est du côté américain du côté européen
à nos côtés il y avait médicaux
internations d'allemagne et miles
advisory group d'angleterre et tous
ensemble nous avons scellé une alliance
avec une poignée de pays emmenés par le
canada et cette coalition a conduit la
communauté internationale à renoncer aux
mines antipersonnel et à la signature du
traité d'interdiction des mines
antipersonnel ou traité d'ottawa signé
par 122 pays en décembre 1997
quelques semaines après l'attribution du
prix nobel de la paix aux ong de la
campagne en
cinq petites années d'une intense
mobilisation grandement facilité par
l'émergence des nouvelles technologies
cette alliance inhabituelle a réussi à
démontrer qu'on pouvait changer le cours
des choses jugées 'sans pour la première
fois dans l'histoire du désarmement
la communauté internationale a renoncé à
une arme conventionnelle
la nouvelle diplomatie était né alors
maintenant je voudrais vous parler
d'une nouvelle mobilisation collective
united against any man ray ou l'alliance
contre l'inhumanité cette campagne elle
est portée par une poignée d'individus
résolu avec le soutien de plusieurs ong
n a ni plus ni moins que l'ambition de
faire reculer
l'inhumanité grandissante à laquelle on
assiste tous la crise syrienne
le yémen la somalie le sud soudan la
république centrafricaine la république
démocratique du congo congo la crise
d'héroïne gas bref vous vous posez la
question de savoir comment quoi faire
pour agir pour conjurer le pire
à notre échelle de citoyens alors pour
illustrer cette problématique je vous
invite à regarder ces quelques images
[Musique]
et
voilà ce que ça donne en image fixe et
voilà comment ça dévastent l'intimité
des familles alors pour décrire un petit
peu cette cette descente aux enfers
cette spirale de la dégradation du droit
international humanitaire
il faut garder à l'esprit que ce qu'on
appelle les lois de la guerre
en d'autres termes qui interdisent de
faire la guerre n'importe comment sont
des acquis des grands massacres
contemporain et ce à quoi on assiste
aujourd'hui c'est véritablement un
retour de comportement barbare en ayant
recours à la guerre totale chaque fois
qu'on considère que ses intérêts
supérieurs sont en jeu et ça c'est
extrêmement préoccupant parce que
finalement au fil du temps ça fait sept
ans que ça dure en syrie l'indignation
devient silencieuse
les opinions publiques finissent par
accepter la différence s'installe
et
finalement au bout du goût la
disponibilité à l'accueil des réfugiés
se durcit alors cette campagne cette
alliance contre l'inhumanité ans en
devenir elle ce qu'elle veut incarner un
sursaut des sociétés civiles parce que
l'expérience nous a appris que seule une
mobilisation puissante
et de refus par la société civile
a des chances d'être audible par les
gouvernements l'objectif c'est 2
rassembler les ong les académiques les
autorités morales et tous les individus
qui le souhaiteront pour refuser cet
état de fait
objective c'est d'affirmer
tous ensemble
les civils doivent être protégés que le
droit d'asile doit être respectée et que
l'impunité ne doit pas devenir la règle
et c'est au service de cette finalité
que nous avons entrepris un certain
nombre de consultations nous sommes
réunis avec tout un réseau de gens qui
sont soit des anciens humanitaire soit
des académiques soit des représentants
des autorités morales diverses
nous sommes réunis à londres à genève
paris à maputo au mozambique à beyrouth
au liban
un binôme peine récemment et nous
préparons des rencontres à à berlin à
nairobi lie à bangkok pour que cette
alliance soit véritablement le reflet
d'une mobilisation des sociétés civiles
de l'ensemble des zones de la planète et
nous avons commencé à poser un certain
nombre d'objectifs alors à court terme à
long terme pardon c'est bien sûr la
restauration du respect des règles qui
interdisent d'une barre de cibler des
villes de cibler des infrastructures non
militaire de cibler des hôpitaux
c'est aussi les règles qui interdisent
le siège des villes et le le déni
d'accès à l'aide humanitaire aux
populations civiles qui sont prises en
otage
et puis c'est aussi veiller à tout ces
législations notamment européennes qui
ne sont ni plus ni moins qu'un déni du
droit d'asile
une autre chose qui nous semble très
importante c'est d'établir un
observatoire humanitaire indépendant de
façon à analyser documenté et dénoncé de
manière systématique chaque année
violations du droit international
humanitaire ainsi que celle du droit
d'asile
il n'existe pas d'instrument indépendant
de cette nature et c'est sans doute pas
par hasard
donc ça c'est un chantier qui est
intéressant parce que ça va
véritablement créer une perspective
nouvelle
enfin si cet observatoire été mis en
place on pourrait par la suite publié un
index d'inhumanité
alors est ce que toutes ces mesures sont
atteignables sont réalisables
l'observatoire est réalisable parce que
beaucoup de gens considèrent que ce
serait une véritable nécessité
nous sommes nous sommes conscients que
ce ne sera pas facile mais nous à
travers ces consultations que nous
menons qui représente environ 250
personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils sont tous
des gens qui ont eu ou encore des
responsabilités dans le système qui le
connaissent de l'intérieur et qui sont
déterminés à le critiquer en
connaissance de cause
nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux à
croire que la nouvelle diplomatie tels
que je voulais défini peut avoir un
impact significatif pour un une
restauration de du respect des règles du
droit international humanitaire
mais nous ne sommes pas naïfs nous
savons que ce sera complexe et que ça
peut être vouée à l'échec
mais en revanche nous nous interdisons
de ne rien faire
au minimum ce que nous aimerions réussir
ces deux d'entretenir un état d'esprit
de résistance fiévreuse au coeur de la
société civile un état de refus de non
consentement de nonac yes man à ce qui
se passe et au final un terreau fertile
à la reconquête du principe d'humanité
quand cela sera le moment et j'ai à
dessin choisi cette photo pour la
conclusion de ce dead
cette chaise qui mesure quand même 12
mètres de haut a été installée par
handicap international dans le cadre de
sa lutte contre les mines antipersonnel
sont pierre rasch et symbolise l'infamie
de manière visible l'infamie qui est
fait à un individu à sa famille à sa
communauté
à chaque explosion d'une mine
antipersonnel au moment du traité d'oslo
nous l'avons re dédié dans sa position
elle fait face à la vallée des drapeaux
du palais des nations unies elle est là
en permanence de lavaur dédié aux à la
lutte contre les conséquences des bombes
à sous-munitions et tout récemment
nous lui avons donné une nouvelle
signification qui est justement de
refuser farouchement la spirale actuelle
et l'accélération de la violence sur la
planète
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]